today on our show Comic Con coming on
all over your face neck and chest man
we're gonna talk about comic comic talk
about Flash talking about a book
inspired man we talk about a lot of [ __ ]
don't go away it's coming up right now
on just a new episode of fat man I'm
Batman
Oh welcome to another episode of fat man
I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith from Auburn
and guess what kids we're like a [ __ ]
dick hair away from comic-con it's about
to happen you can't stop it from [ __ ]
happen and when I say comic-con I just
don't mean some regional comic-con I'm
talking about the granddaddy of all
Comic Cons with the grandmammy if you
will the San Diego with it called
comic-con international : 78 San Diego
but we all know it as a San Diego
comic-con this is gonna be [ __ ] a fun
fun year ladies gentlemen because DC's
going yeah
Marvel's going huh huh Fox is not going
No but after the last x-men movie yeah
it's okay yeah but they got Deadpool so
they were welcome anytime paramount is
going they're bringing Star Trek the
premiere of stars are showing Star Trek
there yeah that's what world premieres
Wednesday night at comic-con what else
Star Wars will be there road 1 will be
there so do you think we'll see new
footage all right hope so they're doing
the panel I'll tell you one thing I'm
not following the Star Wars panel this
year I learned my lesson last year oh
yeah I mean celebration is I think soon
in London and that's right they'll
probably hold on to their [ __ ] neck
for that right because they that's fan
service to the ultimate for sure
celebration one thing you go to San
Diego comic-con and stuff that's lovely
but celebration is their base yeah
they're smart enough to create a Star
Wars con you know not idiots those know
alright so but hey you've left [ __ ]
one very important show off the list
gonna be a Comic Con that's right fat
man on Batman live not that [ __ ] live
at show American comedy club yes
Thursday night 8 o'clock get tickets at
sea smog calm Thursday night the
beginning the official beginning of the
con come hang out with us like you won't
be tired yet used to be fresh this would
be waiting to be funny like so come on
down and we'll speculate on what they're
about to say on Friday and Saturday
because we won't know it'll be amazing I
know and come see us live I'm all over
the place come come this year I'm doing
coverage for IMDB some interview people
I got panel in Hall H yet again trying
after last year hopefully people will be
there and stuff we're gonna show footage
from the geeking out show from yoga
hosers what else am i doing down there
why are you moderating a panel
moderating a preacher panel for the
preacher show for a full good folks AMC
and Seth and Evan what else am i doing I
don't know I've seen a schedule and it's
like this is the busiest I've ever been
at San Diego all good stuff all for good
reason stuff we're shooting some of the
geeking out show while we're down there
as well so yeah it's a gonna be a lively
[ __ ] show but you can come see me and
mark me and Jason are doing a show Jay
and Silent Bob get old
me and Ralph Garman doing Hollywood
babble-on and stuff at me and Mark kick
it all off on Thursday night Batman I'm
Batman live it come
what are you looking forward to seeing
most at Comic Con this year give him a
single yeah the thing I found out a
couple days ago that it's probably
happening they're still very like we're
pretty sure it's gonna have been well
sure
aliens 30th anniversary the entire cast
will be there really yes so Lance
Henriksen Bill Paxton Michael Biehn
carry him noot Sigourney Weaver really
newts gonna be there it's gonna be the
newts not actress she got a game she's
gonna be another one she'll probably act
again if she goes comic-con season like
you're Jesus be like why did I quit we
always come at night mostly we all love
you mostly and Jim Cameron all right
yeah the gang will be here oh this is so
busy making avatar movies I couldn't
imagine he has time for something right
now pushes average our movies back again
didn't he yeah and they're making like
12 of them at this point this is at the
same time that's the question I want to
ask that pal hey what the [ __ ] going
on avatar
now your [ __ ] business clarkey I need
more blue kitties yeah I love blue [ __ ]
show it to me Jim
that's a panel worth [ __ ] going yeah
for sure for nude alone dude seriously
like nude is like one of the greatest at
least in that film that's one of the
greatest children's performances of all
time hmm
and then David Fincher new trellised her
in thank you just came up with that
registry thing opening [ __ ] moments
of Allen three we've loved her to death
in aliens and [ __ ] Ripley goes out of
her way to save this [ __ ] ragamuffin
yep and in the opening credits off
screen she died yeah her sleep Hicks who
also we liked da yeah everyone you liked
his dad and now she's gonna hang out
with British prisoners this [ __ ]
filmmaker has no future I screamed at
the screen dad by those words I'll never
work a good filter hey man tell him
about your [ __ ] Fight Club
oh this was good [ __ ] so here's the
thing I went to go see Fox has this like
Fox movie club for people who work for
Fox and their friends and press where
once a month they'll screen a classic
movie from the Fox library where on the
Fox lot oh yeah so you get to walk by
the giant mural of John McClane and you
get to walk by visit our to show her
mark whips out his [ __ ] yes huge
phone of fides dick wears like I was on
the Fox lock [ __ ] you know what they
make their Simpsons so Marge
all right so going to the lot is you
going to luck and I'm the zanuck theater
that's what I saw one of the Star Wars
movies the last one I think so yeah and
and so this month was Fight Club which I
haven't seen since God maybe this I
haven't seen in theaters since its
opening run I haven't seen in any
fashion in like 9 or 10 years maybe but
I remember loving that movie when I
first saw it because it speaks to you as
a young person who is saying gree and
you're a lot in life possibly a little
frustrated and you're sort of lack of
mobility in your that you when you saw
the movie you're like this is I am
[ __ ] Tyler Durden I mean it was 99
and so like I was employed but like he
wasn't married
yet like didn't have a family when you
get man I got married later in 99 like I
was [ __ ] useless man untethered
where'd you get married like three
months after movie until we get married
three but that's your point is it's a
madman
it's a mad movie it's it's a mad
masculine movie like it's about dudes
who have this pent-up rage so they can't
write give voice to and they can't
really have an outlet for and when I saw
that movie this time I just like halfway
through and I was like holy [ __ ] this is
kind of like a how-to guide to build a
domestic terrorist like it is here's how
we find here's how we identify these
people who feel disenfranchised you feel
lost in the world who who are angry for
reasons that are sort of unknown to
anybody else or reasons for reasons for
reasons of you are you are not your
fancy closet you are not the car you
drive you are not the house you live in
you know we've been raised by a
generation of women and so we are
longing for the masculine air lives we
should be hunter and gatherers and that
collectors and buyers and all of this
stuff like having people always raised
by women yeah I guess especially like
when we go to war dudes are in Normandy
even like [ __ ] like you know when
people had kids cuz like we need someone
to chop the wood let's talk and have a
kid generally the mother was always the
primary caregiver yeah until like the
kid was big enough to swing an axe and
it's like meet your father I never quite
understood that maybe it's just I'm more
like [ __ ] I grew up far more feminine
most butch dudes it was enjoy [ __ ]
Fight Club but I remember watching that
movie and being like I don't feel this
way yeah I would have been one of the
people that they victimized you would
have been on the other end of Project
Mayhem yes I watched that movie I knew
that right away I was like these boys
these are tough boys just like the top
boys mom told me to avoid in school they
want to damage things and they're mad
but yeah like and just watching that
like identifying that kind of rage that
doesn't have an outlet and then pushing
that rage into violence it's kind of
what that movies about and I'd never
noticed that before also I was not
thinking about domestic terrorism in
1999 in a way that we are now thinking
about both terrorism both domestic and
abroad of
holy [ __ ] yeah this is how you
radicalize people they had like I
remember watching it there were shades
of like not quite Timothy McVeigh but
like oh you know they blew up a [ __ ]
building Unabomber in the World Trade
Center the first things in the ether of
like oh oh but now yeah i would imagine
two completely different viewing it's
totally you know any even looking at you
know stuff like isis and this is this is
just how you get people to do things
that they normally wouldn't do by
stoking the fire that's within them and
giving them the voice that they don't
have and telling them you're not alone
for feeling this way we all feel this
way you know how we don't feel its way
let's blow some [ __ ] up maybe we won't
feel that way anymore or maybe we blame
something else for the reasons why we
feel this way maybe we can make America
great again maybe we could seems like it
could be the it is very much the like
hey guys we realize that you you thought
you had the world by the balls but now
you kind of don't let me explain to you
whose fault it is
mmm for taking your jobs or running the
country into the ground or is who do
they blame in Fight Club system it's
yeah I mean the big the big quest of
Project Mayhem is to destroy the credit
card companies you know like they're
they're dropping like all of the huge
monolith buildings and like it would
we'll just we'll wipe it clean you guys
but wipe the slate clean but it's just a
society that has been keeping the man
down i'ma what a weird image it was to
and the buildings at the end like they
spoilers they blow up anyway
boom they start going down and [ __ ] and
that movie came out 99 Saint Mary was
Dogma two years later we would see like
what really happens when a building yeah
goes down at the hands of radicalized
and at the end of that movie it is
literally like Hello Bonham Carter and
Ed Norton holding hands watching the
other were like it's a romantic scene
it's you know [ __ ] Wow we wish we didn't
this didn't happen but we're here like I
got you at the end of the world babes
like that's what that is it is a
romantic version of being a terrorist
it's [ __ ] up oh we watch that movie I
thought it was about dudes punching each
other that movie [ __ ] scared me for
that reason alone cuz I was like I ain't
like these people like I couldn't take
one of those punches right
remember when he [ __ ] pounds on [ __ ]
Leto at one wins like I just wanna break
I just wanted to destroy something
beautiful oh my god
around these people man I'm like can't
we just watch the television I mean it's
also about like mental illness and it's
also about you know abuse and self abuse
and all that like it's about a lot of
things but the thing I never knew that
it was about was that and the holy [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] means something because
mark as we all know rights for legit
[ __ ] newspaper man LA Times and [ __ ]
you should write a piece on it is there
an anniversary coming up 99 so right now
be the 17th anniversary not quite so
three years away from between yeah we'll
save it they'll probably suck that
movie's dick on this 2010 oh yes Vegas a
[ __ ] about dog my village ever happened
to Noah guys a [ __ ] pitcher this
money was born is worried to find the
Fincher [ __ ] and [ __ ] it's a wit of
like I remember that was the first movie
I took my kid to see when she was three
weeks old and a bassinet that's the only
way to do with she slept through most of
us she was not impressed not so much
last [ __ ] when I write yelled at by
two ladies in the theater tooling
keeping a baby to this movie I was like
she didn't say a word quite clearly I
can and I did and I will continue Lodi
dad um alright enough about [ __ ] pass
let's talk about the goddamn [ __ ]
future my club Wow that's your
granddad's movie this is the [ __ ]
future right here and the future we talk
about spider-man let's start there we'll
start there spider-man kids is a
character created by Stan Lee back in
the spider-man homecoming is what's
going to be happening next 4th of July
this year from this 4th of July this
year we have to suffer through the
indignity of Independence Day resurgence
we're not not good apparently a lot of
people didn't go no but next
Independence Day
whip whip flip it's gonna be whip city
man oh my god it's gonna be spider-man
shooting webs and then us in the
audience shooting our own [ __ ] webs
because holy SH it's two hours of the
good spider-man the one who was awesome
in the one half hour of the Civil War
imagine we got two hours and [ __ ] and it
takes place in high school and the tone
is hugely and I heard like John Hughes
and Tony Stark is also in that movie
come on who else is in all my [ __ ]
money I'm gonna make it rain all over
your dicks here [ __ ] I can't wait to
see that movie man I cannot wait I must
say it again give me the close-up you're
doing can't wait to see that movie that
boy was named Tom Holland Tom Holland Oh
Tom Holland's Opus [ __ ] mr. Holland's
Opus I will cry at that beautiful coal
I'll [ __ ] roll a chair because this
kid [ __ ] did something I said it
before I'll say it till the day I die
spider-man lives in Queens this is the
first person that ever made that sound
like it's true even in the cartoons they
didn't bother just sound like he's from
generic Ville USA but this kid was like
you know Tony Stark
but he was [ __ ] so good I would watch
a whole movie about him and we're gonna
watch it yes so a year from now it's
about to happen they got some shots up
man first shots of Tom Holland look he's
that real he's got a bad back oh is that
real that's from the movie it's not from
looper I don't remember looper looking
like that yeah I remember that scene in
looper where spider-man shows over the
pass and gets [ __ ] shot by an older
spider-man
like no dog he's wearing a diaper in a
shot on a [ __ ] car so wait this is
part of the movie right here look at his
eyes they look weird
I'm sure they'll see because it's all CG
yeah zippy zippy
Wow he looks like spider-man from The
Electric Company Carter the one that was
real good at reading and [ __ ] you didn't
speak though he was mute yes like it was
always whoop word balloons I'm jealous
yes he was very moving shots and stuff
give toilet paper eyes and clean nose
deep [ __ ] seventies cut oh my god it's
like oh my gosh
you kids got the Internet we had clay on
there that's about science back then
they gave us some real [ __ ] man you
imagine it was just like people got
hired to like what are we doing this for
Lex and kids cartoon show like whatever
man let's make it funky come on Judy
father like just cuz it's a kid's song
don't mean we got poor Don do it I saw
all of this is accurate but I think I
saw on YouTube new schoolhouse rocks
really that were about finance I mean we
learned about legal legislations and
[ __ ] saying like I gotta I was going
through and I was like is this real and
I thought like in the age of the
internet anybody can make their own
School House Rock down have a
looked kind of realistic but it seemed
like it was on a page of something that
was legit like they've since made more
that nobody [ __ ] told me and Emily
tell you if they're doing about banking
and [ __ ] that would be good to know I'm
45 I don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] I'll be
helpful if they do a schoolhouse rocky
will also explain the end of trading
places like us orange futures futures so
important I don't understand crashing
the economy with fruit like a bacon
lettuce and tomatoes Thank You Billy
hey Murphy looks to camera yeah that'd
be helpful all right anyway back to this
spider-man movie is gonna be [ __ ]
amazing kids even though in those
pictures he looks like the [ __ ] easy
reader version of spider-man he's got
the same eyes he's been real back here
what do you think what was that in the
scene with the with the that cement
cylinder producer Matt checking in
ladies John I'm just so happy that
there's a spider-man movie that has a
field trip as a major plot point right
it's all set high school is so great
maybe they'll have a heavy petting scene
who's invited manga is the second or
someone gets a second on spider-man Wow
under the Mary Jane is like under his
[ __ ] touch as his boob he's like I'm
not ready
WME Sammer's like no flash did that you
see i'm finallys like put her in a
friend zone can't do it can't do it and
it's all he wanted in life under the
costume over the bra flash don't wear no
spider there mate that's true okay to
have to man [ __ ] swinging around like
to keep that shitty let's not give him
form like yeah Holly like put on a
monkey needs a tax like a Batman suit um
what I love memory of in Civil War how
could we forget it just happened like a
minute ago but when he's talking about
like you know before it happened I never
played football before it happened so it
feels wrong to play
but he's like the spider-man I want to
see two hours of the spider-man
seriously they don't even have to put
him in the costume it was just that kid
talking to Queen accent boo Queens
accent is sitting there talking about
the moral obligation of being a hero you
get your own [ __ ] money
pretty throw in [ __ ] Robert Downey
jr. to come in and to do what they did
in civil war even if the exact same
[ __ ] scene even if it was just him
making out with Marisa Tomei in the
background and [ __ ] Tom Holland up
front telling me [ __ ] about his life
cool because hey I'm entertained by the
foreground and be second viewing you
know I'm pulling it because that's like
watching a dirty sequel to only you or
Chaplin what we finally get to see them
giving this spider-man homecoming the
porn version see you mmm ing it's not
happen it is doesn't happen already yeah
it's it's it's already not only a case
of a war porn did they put in Michael
Keaton yet is that official I swear he
was in he was out who's in so okay so
it's official
we all think he's vulture nobody's
confirmed that yet now we all thought he
was in he wasn't and then now he is so
he is officially in the cast
Martin stars in the cast from freaks and
geeks and of course Silicon Valley it
looks like a principal looks like a
science teacher if ever did see one do
you think so the short sleeves and tie
definitely speaks of like physics
amazing Hughes Curt Connors pretty
conversation this movie looks amazing
dude I mean Tyne Daly's been cast Cagney
and or Lacey is [ __ ] a man does aunt may
need a mom man wow man
he's the goods you make she's the
principal of the school there's a writer
always working on Queen science needs a
principal I can't wait the spider-man
movie I can't wait I can't wait new
shoes new shoes oh wait my baby I'm
sorry that's songs
TV shows flash kids let's talk about the
flash TV show I was supposed to go shoot
episode 5 I believe I'm shooting episode
7 because I had a little date conflict
with yoga which comes out September 2nd
so I think like September 3rd I go wow
up to like right from there pretty oh
yeah that [ __ ] leave there and crying
because the movies dying at the
box-office I'm sure if I if it's
anything like my other films and then
immediately start doing a new episode of
the flash well while I'm there though
mark I may actually [ __ ] get to work
with someone else from house Slytherin
whoa I have worked with of course the
great Alan Rickman who was Severus Snape
of how slither you're going to cross
ones with this time well that sounds
filthier than I right I could get into
DIC stuff with this out should we go tom
felton speaking of the the wand choosing
the wizard tom felton who is we all know
him by his real name in the movies Draco
Malfoy
has joined the cast of the flash fastest
man alive he's playing a character
called Julian Dorn a fellow CSI at the
Central City Police Department who
suspects there's more to Barry Allen
than just this good guy reputation hmm
now meanwhile we also happen to know for
a fact thanks to Twitter this week that
season 3 of the flash as we suspected
based on the season finale of episode of
season 2 they are indeed doing
flashpoint
the entire season or just like I'm not
I'm gay I got to imagine I mean look I
can't I don't know the right [ __ ] 23
episodes of a series of anything but you
could pull a whole season out of that
storyline but you're right it's like
it's it is so vastly different than the
normal show maybe a truncated half
season version makes more sense right
but either way I'm [ __ ] there man
it's crazy and Grant Gustin who plays
Barry Allen the flesh so brilliantly he
tweeted it and he said he's if first he
was like playing on Twitter he's like I
just read the season sees the season the
episode 1 script for season 3 he's like
I wish I could tell you the title and
then bruh Lance he got on Twitter after
is a good day and then he said its flash
point no [ __ ] internet was like well
you're right I wonder if they'll do it
for the whole season
well it's also that technically if
they're gonna do flash point given now
as connected as these universes are yeah
it should spill into Supergirl should
spill into era which it's spill until
Isis it tomorrow and whether or not all
of those shows want to be doing a year
of flashpoint that's true you know it
would give an opportunity on a green
arrow though to like no I mean of course
correct some some people are unhappy
with the direction it took or whatever
it just gives you nothing but
opportunities to tell different kind of
stories they've added we talked about I
think on the Indianapolis show but they
added two characters to green arrow to
arrow arrow this season wild dog who's
gonna be played by Ric Gonzales who was
in the future in that preacher [ __ ]
damn it
Reaper yes sounds like Richard if the
Reaper pilot rejected he was on the
Reapers at Reacher which is a whole
different [ __ ] show about a dude in
prison who's just the king of the
reach-around and they're riding wild dog
and they're also adding vigilante yes
Adrian chase I believe that character's
name was correct me if I'm correct and
he that's two more vigilantes so it
feels like arrow season is gonna be very
vigilante heavy yeah which is what he is
sir maybe it's
as a matter of him going here you guys
like I'm not doing it anymore I need
some help is he not doing any well it's
more like I could maybe a mayor now or
I'm running from me I saw a low piece of
an episode from last season like one I
think might have been the season finale
and there's some like he was not I saw
some street fighting but there was
something about him being the mayor or
something yeah I don't know if he got
elected I'm still 9 episodes behind on
arrow but maybe I don't know is he easy
the mayor now alright spoilers he's the
mayor mayor Queen I don't have to watch
those nine episodes service for all
people I saw he said recently people
have asked him online about like me
writing on the show directing on the
show but he was like he's not directing
this season as far as I know but that
could change never can tell I'll go
there and heartbeat if they like hey man
you want to come up [ __ ] yeah I already
heard like whispers of Supergirl as well
yeah I would love to go up there
especially like now it's on CW so you
get to like cross-reference the other
shows and [ __ ] like that as long as you
can have Barry get Cara some more ice
cream that'd be amazing
it was just like barb grant for like a
scene yeah but you just run in and give
her ice cream this is hers you're having
a bad day ice cream again everybody
who's like [ __ ] this man I ship West
Island they don't [ __ ] know the girl
on that show yeah man it's it's gonna be
an exciting [ __ ] season the flesh but
now tom felton you think that's real
that logline about here's his
character's name is random mix random
Julianne Dorn that's not a DC character
that I'm aware of right Julian day I
think his calendar man but Julian Dorn
mm-hmm then so it could be a cover you
wonder if it's a little bit of the like
now this isn't calm in the Star Trek
movie because I mean think about every
character they put on that show Barry
Allen comes from comics Tyrus comes from
comics Cisco comes from comics killer
frost comes comes from comics like it
you know Joe West did he is that
character existing
stood in the retconning I don't think so
that was Joe West might be character
they created for the show hmm
iris is dead just like we need an adult
I'm sure he's amazing I watched this
[ __ ] short it's not sure it's
actually a long documentary they did
this thing called chasing flash the
journey of Kevin Smith if you buy its
flash season 2 box set is out and it's
also available on streaming on iTunes
and stuff but it's an hour-long
documentary about me directing up so the
flash honestly hands down one of the
[ __ ] best things ever seen in my life
not just because I'm involved in big
Kevin Smith fan so obviously was an easy
watch for me but it's really inspiring
it makes you want to go make some [ __ ]
and it shows you how that show gets made
and like what a good time it is and so
it was real I enjoyed watching the pen
like it was good time so check that out
like if you buy the box set you'll see
it and stuff or if you just download
them so if some people don't buy that
Hardware anymore they just dream at all
I think it's a it's on iTunes is where I
[ __ ] watch it but I can't wait to go
back but I do honestly feel like it's a
code yeah you know what I'm saying like
they very rarely like here's a character
you never heard of they even like throw
away characters remember like [ __ ]
they did Linda like you know that's dr.
light like they could adjust that could
have been anyone USA and they [ __ ]
turn to they pull from the comics so
this smells suspicious could be nothing
could be like hey we just made up again
mmm but could be that that guy's gonna
be somebody else it could be it could be
another Thawne maybe think so
it could be it's true depending on which
story they're doing yeah it could be
younger
eobard thawne yeah because older one was
that of existence but Tom Welling is
Bettany Tom often stupid
Superman is back Tom Cavanagh sir more
like I'm back holy [ __ ] the guy for
funny
okay Tom Cavanagh signed on for the
whole season
Wow that's awesome so but I mean like
they gotta be doing some of the your
borrowed phone I mean number one if
you're doing flashpoint your Bart Thawne
reverse-flash is the guy who's at the
ends ik Oh Barry you [ __ ] this all up
but I don't I don't know I know maybe
I'm just like smelling smoke where
there's no fire or maybe a wishful
thinking but like it just seems weird
that they were just Julien doing yeah
seems a little too made-up I mean I know
they're all made up including Barry
Allen in a flash but just seems a little
like you look over here it's a bag of
magic tricks man that they're cooking up
for this new season and [ __ ] I get those
a thing about magic tricks well I'm
gonna get to look in the bag a couple
weeks when I finally go up there first
week of September man I know was it July
fourth now so yeah August September eyes
go wait two more months so as a as a
filmmaker as a director I'm like yeah I
look forward of course to going up there
I had a great time doing it but it's a
[ __ ] fan dude I just want to know
what's gonna go on and tell me I know
and I'll know I have today
they'll have to show me the episodes
that I didn't work on or at least let me
read the scripts that's what they did
last time it's the best part of the job
cuz suddenly you're like I know she had
others dog I just power and then you go
make the episode which is fun as well
yeah man so I can't [ __ ] wait for
that that whole block CW shows one more
show you add one more at the end of the
season because you got green arrow if
you got flash wouldn't I keep saying
Reena got arrow you got flash legends of
tomorrow
Supergirl if you added like a Friday
show mm-hmm every day lane turn or
something like that they're getting
closer to there in a world where they
have Superman now to play with ain't
gonna be long before suddenly like I bet
you Batman shows up in one of these
shades would be [ __ ] Batman in the
hands of Berlanti Burrell auntie Batman
Andrew Kreisberg Batman you didn't know
you wanted that until I just said it out
loud now you're like take both of my
testicles just just like Andrew
Kreisberg Batman it's like I didn't know
that I wanted the lesbian Queens of
Westeros until do you see that scene
where it's [ __ ] Greyjoy and Daenerys
Lee yes you
should marry each other we should have
this all the time yes take your I was
sitting there at the table right I was
just going everything about that season
finales [ __ ] phone those last two
episodes they a great season
yeah like across the boards the Hodor
episode was the high point [ __ ] like
that but like it's not even saying like
and then it was downhill from there
because [ __ ] battle the bastards and
then the season finale insanely [ __ ]
strong like really wonderful
storytelling where they're like we're
gonna satisfy the [ __ ] he's like getting
like [ __ ] and the best possible way
like all-nighter where you're like
you're still thinking about it years
later the lesbian Queens of Western we
should there it is for comic-con coming
flash coming
spider-man homecoming and and a little
bit of Game of Thrones forty there is
they'll sue song sue song of Westeros ah
there it is lots of good [ __ ] to look
forward to including our next episode
well we'll tell you about the Batman V
Superman Ultimate Edition yes submit
edition
on the next episode of fat man Batman
until then man I've been Kevin Smith and
I'm mark barnard and this has been
Batman I'm Batman tune in next time same
bat time same bat Channel podcast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
a man's meat Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder